howdy folks maximum again here for
another GS news update where a new
titanfall DLC and update were detailed
earlier today and we've got all the hot
details for you right here the frontiers
edge DLC is arriving next Thursday on
July thirty-first for Xbox one and PC
and features three new maps export is
set on the side of a mountain the top of
the hill is a great vantage point for
Titans to take out exposed pilots the
map Haven takes place at a beach resort
on the edge of a massive Lake allowing
pilots to bounce around the skyscraper
walls there are some large interior
spaces many of them not accessible by
Titans the last map dig site is set in a
rocky valley featuring giant rocks off
developers from respawn said during the
live stream that this was their favorite
map from the DLC pack update number five
for titanfall is also going to hit July
thirty-first the largest feature to be
added to the game is the black market
which runs on in-game currency which is
earnable by trading in burn cards and
completing daily achievements and
challenges from the black market you can
pick up new bern cards as well as Titan
insignias besides bug fixes the update
brings new achievements and daily
challenges as well as an emblem for gin
one player and PC players running
multiple graphics cards will be happy to
hear that they are adding multi-gpu
support I know when the frontiers edge
launches on July thirty-first we're
going to do a full rundown over here on
gamespot com so be sure to stay tuned
and look forward to that